I wonder if king size sheets are called
presidential sized in England
I really should have a tweeter account
yes
hey how'd the Run go uh pretty good I
finished that's great
why is that great because he
accomplished something what was your
mile time
about seven
I could beat that on a skateboard well
that has wheels yeah well my feet don't
and I could still Crush that time really
Dwight how fast are you let's just put
it this way last weekend I outran a
black pepper snake really I am fast
to give you a reference point I'm
somewhere between a snake and a mongoose
and a panther
man what is taking Toby so long oh I'll
just time him later and you'll compare
the times
yeah
are you ready
I can't
am I being mean to Dwight
I don't know I did just make him run
around the building and I have no
intention of timing him
this isn't even a stopwatch it's a
digital thermometer
he does make my life harder sometimes
and on purpose like he tried to put
meters on the bathroom stalls as a way
of bringing in more money for the
company
hey three more laps to laps go
you gotta pick it up if you're gonna
beat Toby
I should probably get back to work
[Music]
[Laughter]
twice
oh no yes take my ride okay okay
seriously okay okay
yes I have a wig for every single person
in the office
you never know when you're gonna need to
Bear a passing resemblance to someone
I just want it to stop
here we go College Road Show gotta bring
our a game
what is the most inspiring thing I ever
said to you
don't be an idiot changed my life
whenever I'm about to do something I
think would an idiot do that and if they
would I do not do that thing
oh man is that a prism Duro sport
you've seen one of these yeah they're
like an iPod only they're better because
they're chunkier and more solid
Roy gave it to me for Christmas I'm
trying to figure out how to put songs on
it no no don't go there
I know this Russian website where you
can download songs for two cents a piece
really yeah I'll write down the address
for you
only the only thing is is that all the
songs are in Russian
kidding
oh
why would they all be
okay see you later pan
give me a cup of coffee me too or do you
also have a monopoly on thirst all right
guys it didn't work out for any of us so
we're still on the same team let me get
these no
let him get his own he's got Syracuse
money you know your partner's got a lot
of attitude but I like that how long you
guys been dating Jim couldn't land me in
a thousand years but you're saying
there's a chance shut up
Cumberland Mills
and how did you get my resume
oh no no I'm very flattered don't get me
wrong I'm just not sure that it's my
official resume or if it's something
that maybe uh
satisfied customer posted online
what does it say under martial arts
training
oh okay I'm gonna have to supplement
that could I have your fax number
would I ever leave this company look I'm
all about loyalty in fact I feel like
part of what I'm getting paid for here
is my loyalty
but if there were somewhere else that
valued that loyalty more highly
I'm going wherever they value loyalty
the most
on or off
off
oh
what is on your face is that a disguise
clown paint
ID badges are long overdue Security in
this office Park is a joke last year I
came to work with my spud gun in a
duffel bag I sat at my desk all day with
a rifle that shoots potatoes at 60
pounds per square inch
can you imagine if I was deranged we are
going to do everything humanly possible
to ensure that this never happens again
well it doesn't help because it already
happened to me the watermark
it's a one-time thing I don't care it
was
the sex appeared to be consensual both
animals were smiling okay I grew up on a
farm I have seen animals having sex in
every position imaginable
goat on chicken chicken on goat
a couple of chickens doing a goat couple
of pigs watching
whoever Drew this got it exactly right
what did I do
I did my job I slashed benefits to the
Bone I saved this company money
was I too harsh Maybe
I don't believe in coddling people
in the wild
there is no health care and the wild
Health Care is
ow I hurt my leg I can't run
a lion needs me and I'm dead
wow
I'm Not Dead
I'm the lion
you're dead just hit me you'll see I
can't because uh just got a manicure so
oh queer
uh queer eye that's a good show
important show
go ahead do it just time to White punch
you oh yeah well that would be kind of
worthless because I know a ton of 14
year old girls are gonna kick his ass
you know a ton of 14 year old girls what
belt are they look Dwight is a wuss when
we rented Armageddon no cried at the end
of it I told you that was because it was
New Year's Eve and it started to snow at
exactly midnight and Bruce Willis
thinking to leave him on the asteroid
okay I'll punch you oh okay here we go
all right come on
oh did I want to harm Michael the one
man I've been hired to protect no I did
not are you okay
make sure you're all right yep
thank you
I come from a long line of Fighters I'm
Eternal grandfather was the toughest guy
I ever knew World War II veteran killed
20 men then spent the rest of the war in
an Allied prison camp
my father
battled blood pressure and obesity all
his life
different kind of fight
as a volunteer sheriff's deputy I've
been doing surveillance for years one
time
I suspected an ex-girlfriend of mine of
cheating on me so I tailed her for six
nights straight turns out she was
with a couple of guys actually so
mystery solved let's go over some of
these symptoms of marijuana use shall we
you tell me who this sounds like
slow moving
inattentive
dull
constantly snacking
shows a lack of motivation
hey
I like the people I work with generally
with four exceptions
but someone committed a crime and I did
not become a Lackawanna County volunteer
sheriff's deputy to make friends
and by the way I haven't
okay I will only need two things a roll
of duct tape and a knife
I'm on it okay 30 minutes or less please
come back
save the receipts
hey what let's see if any of these will
work hey hey White
Dwight I keep various Weaponry
strategically placed around the office
I saved Jim's life with a can of pepper
spray I had velcroed under my desk
people say oh it's dangerous to keep
weapons in the home or the workplace
well I say it's better to be hurt by
someone you know accidentally
than by a stranger on purpose
I wish I could menstruate
if I could menstruate I wouldn't have to
deal with idiotic calendars anymore I'd
just be able to count down from my
previous cycle
unless I'd be more in tune with the moon
and the tides